something that was really important for
us for primal was to make sure the
stories happen in the world were really
intertwined it's part of the far cry DNA
would you fight the way you want you
have all the toys you want you can
explore the way you want it's real you
again that's about freedom and letting
the player decide how he wants to play
the player will beat a [ __ ] Stone Age
hunter looking for his lost people do
when shot the wenja tribe has been
destroyed scattered around by two very
different but very aggressive tribes in
order to reunite the whinger taka we
need to go and explore all of us to try
and find the key members of the tribe
and get them into a safe haven the
village is actually the spine of the
narrative so if you do activities in the
open world you're actually going to
probably free whinger that are going to
make your village grow if you go and do
the main missions you're going to
encounter a new specialist that will
provide you with new skills and
knowledge that will get you stronger far
cry games are about exotic location
places with weird characters but also
about authenticity so when the team
decided to recreate the
proto-indo-european language we turn to
experts that we found to help us
recreate a long way that has been dead
for 12,000 years
we were contacted by Ubisoft to create a
language based off of proto and European
for Far Cry primal first we thought it
was going to be something small and then
it became clear that the entire game was
going to be in at least two if not three
versions of proto-indo-european which is
huge so proto-indo-european was a
language that was spoken thousands of
years ago it's the source of many
languages that are spoken today
languages like English and Spanish and
Russian but also the source of ancient
languages like Latin Greek and Sanskrit
for wing Joe what we wanted to do was to
create a proto proto-indo-europeans
something that goes even further back in
time so we looked at certain very
ancient features of proto indo-european
and we assume them to be the baseline
for not only the winter tribe but also
that WuDunn na kabhi it is bad the
creative team views these Yili as a more
advanced tribe so we thought it would be
a good idea to give them a more advanced
stage of the language wait port hey
shields sometimes we are in into
problems where there weren't words that
we can reconstruct for
proto-indo-european so for example we
know of about 20 different routes for
the verb to shine we have no idea how
they said yes
it's been quite an exciting and even
moving experience to see how the culture
that was dead for a thousand of years
could be brought back
we like to produce game that are set in
in places of times were in addition to a
fan you could learn a little something
or discover something that is part of
our world and our culture's it's this
kind of experience we also wanted to
show you now in Primal show a bit what
was the life of Stone Age hunters and
this is what the player will experience
or Cry primal